our question comes from Alex in Michigan
what's the difference between a home
mortgage through a bank or a credit
union in getting a mortgage to a
mortgage company it might be no
difference depending on how your bank or
credit union did the mortgage there are
three types of mortgages that are called
conforming mortgages Fannie Mae which is
conventional FNMA conventional loans FHA
and VA Federal Housing Administration
the Veterans Administration conforming
means that each of those contendere
making a VA loan that they want the
Veterans Administration to insure has to
conform to a set of Veterans
Administration guidelines so all VA
loans have conformed to a certain
lending process then they can be
packaged together and sold in blocks so
you could take two take five $200,000 VA
loans package them together as a million
dollar block and sell them as a block
that's called securitizing a mortgage
okay same thing with a Fannie Mae loan
all Fannie Mae loans follow the same
guidelines banks and credit unions can
make FHA loans they can make Fannie Mae
loans and they can make VA loans if they
have a mortgage department in them and
then they can sell that loan only if it
is conforming to those guidelines
because no one will buy it if it's not
conforming if it's not predictable
because it was made on a certain set of
guidelines if they just simply lend you
the money from their bank or lend you
the money from their credit union which
can happen that's just a bank loan and
that's what we call a portfolio loan
which means they are going to keep that
loan in their bank they can't sell it
because it doesn't conform no one will
buy it they can't sell it so they have
to keep it in their portfolio and so
they can use whatever lending guidelines
they want
they can just decide home equity loans
are an example of that all home equity
loans are portfolio loans they do not
conform to any set standard guidelines
each bank makes up their own guidelines
and they keep those loans in their own
portfolio meaning that bank lent that
money that bank collects that money that
bank won't sell it but you can almost a
hundred percent of time predict that if
you have a conforming loan it is going
to be sold if you go to Bank X Bank of
America and you love Bank of America
which makes you not smart but if you do
and you use Bank of America and you use
Bank of America do an FHA loan don't be
surprised if two weeks later countrywide
or someone else owns that loan because
Bank of America very likely did not
intend to keep that conforming loan they
set they buy and sell those things like
you sell stock or something else
you can move those loans around easily
now mortgage companies almost never keep
a loan like 99.99% of time like
Churchill mortgage that we endorsed they
do not portfolio anything a hundred
percent of the loans that they make they
have an investor already lined up to
take that conforming loan so if you go
to them and you get a conventional loan
15 year fixed where the payments no more
than 1/4 of your take-home pay like we
talked about all the time
Churchill mortgage will own that lower
loan for about 30 seconds after you sign
all the paperwork it will already be
lined up to be dumped into someone
else's bucket and so don't expect
Churchill to collect payments from you
they're not in that business they set up
the loans sell them into the deal and
that that's simple it's that simple so
you know and this is what gets people in
trouble if you remember back in 2008
when the housing market crash what
happened was a bunch of people were
violating those conforming loans and
some of the appraisers were lying on the
appraisals and so some of the
conventional loans that we had all come
to count on is kind of the gold standard
were bad there was a whole bunch of them
were bad because they were the houses
were overvalued
and so when people quit paying and
walked away from them it started
crashing in on the security side of the
business and these banks that were
holding blocks of these mortgages 10 20
30 million dollar blocks of these
mortgages started caving in and that's
how that's what happened out there
was that people were not following the
conforming guidelines and and the some
of the appraisers were jacked up in the
middle of it and so appraisal the
appraisal world got a lot more
regulation out of that the banking world
and mortgage world got a lot more
regulation made out of that so that we
don't end up with another bubble based
on falsehood and that's the background
on that but that's the deal so you can
get your bank to make a loan of any kind
if they keep it whatever you can dream
up and they dream up and that's the deal
you have that deal as long as they're
going to keep it in their portfolio if
you can talk your credit union into it
do it that's why I send you to the
credit union a lot of times for paying
for a very small mortgage like if you're
getting a $50,000 mortgage on a $200,000
house because you got a big down stroke
you probably can get that with no
closing costs no points on a fixed-rate
better than you could get a conforming
small FHA loan or small Fannie Mae loan
because the mortgage company's going to
tag you with a bunch of stuff you don't
really need to do an appraisal on a
house from a common sense perspective if
you're looking under the $200,000 house
making a $50,000 loan you can kind of go
I think that's safe but if you're doing
a Fannie Mae loan you still have to do
the appraisal you still have to do a
survey you still have to do all this
stuff because you have to conform to
their guidelines and that creates a
bunch of unnecessary closing costs on a
super small loan like that and so if
you're getting a little dinky loan on a
big ol house like that always do that at
your credit union and just say hey I'll
take it like a car payment right we'll
set the thing up on five years
fixed-rate no points no appraisal no
closing costs no nothing just make me a
car loan $50,000 car loan on my two
hundred thousand on our house and as
long as they're keeping that in their
portfolio isn't whatever you can talk
them into and they agree to that becomes
your deal mortgage business become a
very very interesting business and last
few years